see I don't be curly and plays the organ
is on a road trip across the country
everybody makes it notice for a hot skin
[Applause]
people make fun of Asian people for
eating dogs which I understand is or
pick to you guys because in America dogs
are treated like family peppers but in
Asia we treat our family members like
family members since a cultural thing
said by an animal we love my grandma
but you never better deja bless you
happy only CC 30 of the river
my agent friends make fun of me because
I like to eat General Tso's chicken like
Hans isn't general since chicken is a
shitty Americanized version of something
authentically Asian I was like yeah but
so my favorite movies don't shower three
you know I wasn't playing on a subdued
reading a book in Arabic which time free
camp
but then I saw pull the corner the page
put the [ __ ] away and I was like oh
thank god he's got future plans
beginning middle and end and finish the
narrative structure I used to date a
woman who is onz yoga and Chuck sex and
I was like do you enjoy breathing or not
I'm gonna block it well a deal
we can't take a picture
I was tired this videos like we're so
lucky were not gay can you imagine if
most of the gender we were attracted to
wasn't attracted to us back I was like
wow I'm glad we're different I feel like
my new birth we'd be like bro I bet you
can so much protein and creatine
different pregnancy this baby's at 27
pounds when you go six Nacogdoches down
those gains in the first trimester
you're like yeah you're book smart but
I'm street smart oh you're smart the way
that's not measurable or comparable I
could be good for you yes all right
your criminal let's call aggravated
assault stuff much B inverse I'm not a
communist I do support disappoint any
classes I Republicans consider communism
which is whenever two or more people
gathered to do something nice it's a
good day inside of a van because way
evil shelter like the whole thing with
that so even if a date goes well will
use end up happening is we go for a
drive
good courage is neither we arrived 45
minutes ago
I love it yes